some students are not allowed at
henderson rec centers and pools for the
rest of the month this comes as lamping
elementary school continues its two-week
quarantine amid a covid outbreak on
campus so why are city facilities also
being included orco mana is in henderson
tonight to explain
one lamping elementary school parent
tells me when she took her son to the
outdoor pool here at the henderson
multi-generational complex on sunday she
was told his account was flagged for
covet 19 concerns she was nothing short
of surprised we see here in our system
that your child can't come to anything
henderson parks and rec this mom who
does not want to be named tells me
that's what staff told her when she
brought her son to this outdoor
henderson pool this weekend her son is
in first grade at lamping elementary
school and is also enrolled in
henderson's safe key program which is
available at all city rec centers the
city's parks and rec department tells
eight news now that lamping elementary
called to inform them that a safe key
student had come in contact with one of
the students who tested positive for
kovid at lamping due to hipaa they
couldn't know which student it was so
they placed all safety students on a
quarantine list this mom says even her
son's negative covid test couldn't get
him in no parent expects to think that
their child who recently tested negative
for covid wouldn't be allowed to play in
an outdoor pool of you know of all cases
we've learned parents can show their
kids negative covid tests to get an
account flag removed but that must be
done through a covid coordinator not at
the rec centers so i'm appreciative of
that parents tell us the email they got
last week only talked about quarantining
from safe key they did not outline the
facilities that they were going to be
banned from the parks and rec quarantine
ends toward the end of august and while
this parent understands it's all meant
to keep everyone safe she hopes to see
improvements it's just a blanket policy
when you put policy on paper it may look
good but when you actually put policy in
life and see how it affects children
especially you know you need to make
adjustments for more information on how
to get in contact with the covid
coordinators for the city of henderson
head to our website 8newsnow.com
reporting in henderson orca mana 8 news
now